>> ♪ ♪
>> PREPARING TO CELEBRATE
INDEPENDENCE DAY.
TODAY'S JOB NEWS BROUGHT US
SOMETHING ELSE TO CELEBRATE.
THIS MORNING WE LEARNED THAT IN
JUNE, OUR ECONOMY CREATED
850,000 JOBS.
THE STRENGTH OF OUR RECOVERY IS
HELPING US FLIP THE SCRIPT.
EMPLOYERS ARE COMPETING TO
ATTRACT WORKERS.
>> Shannon: OUR PANEL WILL TALK
ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
BYRON YORK AND PHIL HAYES.
EMPLOYERS ALSO HAVE TO COMPETE
WITH FEDERAL BENEFITS EXTENDED
TO WORKERS.
>> EXACTLY.
THE BODY LINE IS 850,000 JOBS.
THAT'S GOOD NEWS.
PRESIDENTS AWN TAKE CREDIT FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENTS EVEN IF
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A LOT TO DO
WITH THEM.
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK A VICTORY
LAP TODAY MAYBE TWO OR THREE AND
DIDN'T TAKE NOTE WHAT HAVE WE
ARE SEEING.
THAT JOB COMPETITION LED TO
RISING WAGES IN SOME PLACES.
THE PRICE OF GAS IS NOT IN THIS
VICTORY LAP THE PRESIDENT TOOK
ATTRIBUTING IT TO HIMSELF AND
THE MASSIVE STIMULUS BILL
DEMOCRATS PASSED A COUPLE OF
MONTES AGO.
>> Shannon: STEVE, THE WHITE
HOUSE PUT OUT A TWEET ABOUT
SAVING 16 CENTS AT THIS YEAR'S
COOK OUT.
PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING WITH GAS.
>> THIS WAS A CURIOUS DECISION
THAT, TWEET.
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT THEY SEE AT THE
GAS TANK AND THE GROCERY STORES.
PEOPLE FEEL THAT INFLATION IS
AFFECTING THEIR OWN REALITY.
THEY WON'T BE PERSUADED BY
A WHITE HOUSE TWEET ABOUT A 16
CENTS SAVING.
THE ROLE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE ROLE OF STATE
IN ENDING THESE $300 PER WEEK
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS,
REPUBLICANS ENDED THEM IN MAY OR
IN EARLY JUNE.
THERE IS MORE TO LEARN AS WE DIG
INTO THE NUMBERS.
I SUSPECT THAT WE WILL LEARN
IT'S NO COINCIDENCE WE SAW
A JUMP IN JOBS AT THE SAME TIME
THESE 2 DOZEN STATES CUT THOSE
OFF.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE TOO.
350,000 OF THOSE JOBS CAME IN
THE HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY WHICH
HAD BEEN STRUGGLING TO FIND
WORKER
WORKERS BECAUSE OF THESE
ADDITIONAL UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS.
THAT'S PARTS OF THE EQUATION
HERE.
>> Shannon: AND TO PUT UP THE
HARD DATA.
GREAT NEWS ADDING 850,000 JOBS.
IT WAS UNEXPECTED THAT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WENT FROM 5.9.
IT WAS GOING TO BE 5.6.
CHARLES, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> I THINK THAT 5.9 IS A PUZZLE.
I SEE IT AS A STATISTICAL NOISE.
THE BROADER UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
THAT INCLUDE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DISCOURAGED FROM SEEKING JOBS,
THAT NUMBER WENT DOWN.
THERE WAS A MIXED PICTURE THERE.
THE BIG PICTURE ON THE U.S.
ECONOMY IS POSITIVE.
WE WENT INTO A DEEP HOLE IN 2020
AND THANKS TO A HUGE AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL STIMULUS AND BANK
STIMULUS WE ARE ZOOMING BACK OUT
OF IT.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS THAT WILL
CONTINUE THROUGH 2021 AND INTO
THE FIRST HALF OF 2022.
MOST OF THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE
SEEMED TO BE THE KIND OF
PROBLEMS YOU HAVE WHEN YOU ARE
GROWING SO FAST THAT YOU CAN'T
KEEP UP.
FACTORIES CAN'T FIND ENOUGH
INPUT.
ESPECIALLY SEMI CONDUCTORS AND
CAN'T FIND ENOUGH WORKERS.
THAT'S SHOWING INFLATION.
I WILL BE CURIOUS TO SEE WHETHER
THIS IN 2022 IS THE ISSUE PEOPLE
VOTE ON OR WHETHER PEOPLE REGARD
THIS COMEBACK AS SOMETHING
INEVITABLE ONCE THE VACCINATIONS
OCCURRED.
WE CAN ARGUE THE WOBBLES IN THE
DATA.
THE BIG PICTURE IS POSITIVE.
>> Shannon: A VERY QUICK COMMENT
FROM YOU GUYS ABOUT THE SUPREME
COURT WRAPPING UP ITS TERM.
IT HASN'T PERFORMED AS SOME OF
THE BEST AND WORST PREDICTIONS
FOR THE COURT.
I GOT A LIST OF ALL OF THE
CLERKS THAT EVERYBODY HIRED FOR
THE FALL.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE ANYBODY IS
GOING ANYWHERE.
CHARLES, WE WILL START WITH YOU.
>> ON THE POINT YOU WERE
ALLUDING TO.
THE NON-RETIREMENT OF JUSTICE
STEVEN BRIAR.
I THINK SOME PEOPLE ARE
DEMANDING THAT HE QUIT OUGHT TO
DO SOUL SEARCHING.
WAS IT A SMART IDEAL TO
HUMILEATE THIS MAN IN THAT WAY?
>> WHAT WE LEARNED ABOUT
DIVIDING THE COURT IN PARTISAN
TERMS DOESN'T FIT IN HERE.
>> Shannon: BYRON?
>> WELL, ON THIS FLOWER SHOP
CASE WE DISCUSSED TONIGHT.
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH ONE THING
WITH THE SUPREME COURT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SOLVE THE
ISSUE HERE.
IN THE CAKE SHOP CASE, IN
COLORADO, THEY SHOULD A VERY,
VERY NARROW OPINION.
NOW THEY HAVE DUCKED THIS ONE.
AT SOME POINT THEY WILL HAVE TO
COME OUT WITH A RULING ON THIS.
BUT SO FAR THEY